this morning we are celebrating two
pioneers in journalism that you might
not have heard of the white house
correspondents association is honoring
alice dunigan and ethel payne with the
creation of a lifetime achievement award
in their names they were the first black
women to be members of the white house
press corps back in the day dunigan died
back in 1983 payne in 1991 tomorrow
night their families will accept the
inaugural dunnigan payne prize for
lifetime career achievement at a dinner
in washington d.c we're all going we
spoke with family members about these
remarkable women
[Music]
in the middle of the 20th century
america was a segregated nation schools
and transportation in the south were
separated based on race and so was the
nation's press
alice dunigan the kentucky born
granddaughter of slaves was determined
to fulfill her dream of becoming a
journalist i am alicia dunigan
and alice dunigan was my grandmother
by the time she reached her thirties
dunnigan had a regular column for a
local paper but she wanted more she said
the two strikes out against her was that
she was black and then she was female
she landed a job in washington d.c
writing for the associated negro press a
wire service for black-owned papers in
1947
alice dunigan became the first female
black reporter credentialed to cover the
white house
i am james johnson jr
and ethel lois payne was my aunt this is
that
for ethel payne the path to journalism
began when she was denied admission to
law school because of the color of her
skin
you couldn't control your opportunity so
you had to be prepared for whatever
opportunity came along writing for her
was a natural something she liked to do
in 1951 payne was hired as a washington
reporter for the chicago defender one of
the country's leading black newspapers
at the time
i don't give a hoot whether you're
democrat or republican in this kind of a
job done again in payne regularly
attended president dwight eisenhower's
news conferences integration of schools
on military posts may be the latest in
1955.
in 1954 just two months after the brown
versus board of education ruling ethel
payne demanded to know whether
eisenhower would support a ban on
segregation in interstate travel
ike did not like that question
i'd like to know if we could assume
that we have administration support in
getting action in this
well i don't know what's right you say
that you
have to have administration support the
administration is trying to do what it
thinks to be
decent and just in this country
the moment sparked headlines of its own
white house press secretary ron ziegler
stated frankly that he was ousted ethel
payne later went on to become the first
black female commentator at cbs news
blacks aren't any different from other
groups of voters
kane and dunnigan were as dedicated to
family as they were to their work
my aunt was a very good cook
i can't think of one thing because
everything she touched was good
she never
too much talked about what she did if
you asked her she would tell you i
remember talking to her one time and we
had finished dinner
and so she said
my doctor said i should stop smoking
cigarettes
so now smoke a pipe
their legacies live on in the work done
by journalists of color today
i have great love and feeling for how
she inspired us
as the next generation
she knocked the door down i marvel at
all that she did and all that she was
and all that she fought for
wow bravo ladies bravo i have to say i'm
embarrassed to say i'd never heard of
either one of them i did not and first
black female on-air commentator at this
network
yes yeah so clearly they have paved the
way vlad you said you had heard of it i
had um and you know what i always think
about when i see a piece like this is we
often talk about you know you need to
see it so you can be it yeah but can you
imagine
if you don't see it and yet you still
are able to become it i i just
being the first as she her daughter just
said or her granddaughter knocking the
doors down
it's hard to stand on somebody's
shoulders when there are no shoulders to
stand on we're the ones standing on her
shoulders exactly right and i didn't
even know that but what i like is that
her relatives are still here to be able
to tell us all about them and what
they've done and how they did it it's
also amazing how quaint your question
was to eisenhower and how
irritated he got well it was a little
bit but compared to today though it
seems like and that was a headline in
the newspaper that exchange that seems
very polite by today's standards